it is super exciting to think and to
know that the mutants are finally going
to debut in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe next year and next year is
almost here so we are not that far away
and according to some new reports Marvel
Studios has a lot of plans for the X-Men
coming up and this is fortunate but also
unfortunate at the same time because it
seems like Marvel Studios has changed
their plans and shifted their focus to
the mutants since they have fired
Jonathan majors and are reported
sweeping Kang the Conqueror under the
rug putting him to the side until the
very end of the Multiverse Saga before
this happened the mutants weren't really
going to be that prominent in the
Multiverse Saga at least not any New
Mutants or new X-Men characters of
course we know that some ogs are
returning of course we're getting
Wolverine in Deadpool 3 along with
probably the original X-Men cast we also
know that they're going to return for
Avengers Secret Wars along with reports
of other iconic Heroes that have played
in previous movies prior to the MCU like
Toby Maguire Spider-Man but any plans
for new Mutant characters weren't really
in the Multiverse Saga however like I
mentioned that seems to have changed now
now Marvel Studios did already kind of
begin their plans for mutants in the MCU
they reccon calicon into a mutant which
they then did in the comics as well
Kevin has reiterated that neyar is
a mutant and of course in Multiverse of
Madness we got Professor X in a very
comic accurate wheelchair SL hoverchair
it's been a good time but we haven't
been hit with the X-Men or mutants full
force yet but it looks like that is
about to change so let's dive into this
new report but if you're new be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos we're also doing a
giveaway more on that in the end
yesterday we went over part of an
article released by Alex P at the cosmic
circus.com and again I encourage you all
to read the entire article we'll link
that in the pin comment down below and
in the article Insider Alex P talks
about the future of Deadpool 3 and the
age of mutants speaking about the X-Men
coming to the MCU next year in 2024 he
States first on the list will be X-Men
97 set to releas sometime around April
May 2024 the project is a direct sequel
to the animated series from the 9s it is
set to continue covering the events of
this universe's iteration of the X-Men
following the conclusion of the Original
Series in 1997 while the direct
connection to the larger MCU remains
unclear sources indicate that these
X-Men will serve as the original
reference for future iterations some
examples include Charles Xavier in
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness and Dr Hank McCoy in the Marvels
both of which are inspired by the
designs of the original Animated Series
this series is also expected to run for
multiple Seasons with the second season
already being developed at the time of
writing this article so that's kind of
cool basically what Alex Perez is
stating here is that Marvel Studios is
taking inspiration from the Animated
Series designs for the live action
designs of the mutants that are already
in the MCU and coming to the MCU but of
course I know what everybody is thinking
that's great for the animated characters
but what about the New Mutants coming to
the MCU the liveaction ones don't worry
the article covers that he States
following the release of X-Men 97 one of
the most highly anticipated projects
coming from Marvel Studios is the
upcoming Deadpool and Wolverine film
this has been teased as a multiversal
road trip movie across several Marvel
universes which will ultimately cross
over and to the main 616 Universe MCU
then he States while we won't directly
spoil what happens in this movie it's an
absolute certainty that the project will
set the stage for what comes next for
the mutants in the main 616 MCU he
States we can confirm from our sources
that there have been discussions about
mutants having a more pronounced role in
the upcoming phase of the Multiverse
Saga than initially anticipated this is
in hopes of establishing mutants in a
more meaningful way on Earth 616 before
the conclusion of the Saga now there's
more to this article including talk
about the Avengers vers X-Men but let's
break down this part first this wasn't
really in Marvel studios's original
plans we mentioned in our video
yesterday that Marvel Studios is
reportedly going to kind of sideline
King until he returns as a bigger batter
villain for Avengers Secret Wars but
essentially we aren't going to see him
until then which of course as we know
was not the plan but since Jonathan
major was found guilty and he is of
course associated with Kang when you
hear Kang you think Jonathan major they
want that to subside they need that to
kind of die down and go away so
essentially Kang is sidelined until
basically all of this news about
Jonathan Majors goes away of course
there's always going to be an
association there with the name but
eventually they will recast him but this
has Marvel shifting their plans in a
really big way Kang was supposed to show
up in many different forms many
different variants all throughout the
MCU in a bunch of different projects
until we eventually got to Secret Wars
now we might just see him one more time
in the MCU in the finale of the
Multiverse Saga Secret Wars but the good
news to that is it looks like the X-Men
are now going to become more prominent
with Kang out Marvel Studios need
something really really exciting for the
Multiverse Saga now and the X-Men are
perfect for that in their original plans
they weren't really going to focus on
the X-men too much until after the
Multiverse Saga but now due to
everything that has taken place we get
them sooner and there is even tox of an
X-Men movie a specific solo X-Men movie
happening before Avengers Secret Wars
and this really could be a perfect way
to get people super excited about the
MCU again especially after what we are
about to see in Deadpool 3 plus this
does set up the next Saga which is going
to focus on the X-Men and the Fantastic
4 it sets it up in a much better way
with a lot more continuity now
apparently Marvel and Disney already
have some ideas of what they are going
to do which of course they do Jonathan
major was arrested in March of this year
they've had N9 months to think about
what they're going to do if he is found
guilty so of course they have ideas of
what they're going to do and they
probably have it pretty close to Locked
In if not they have their full plans
already and according to Alex Perez from
the cosmic circus some ideas include a
mutants series on Disney plus focusing
on individual stories for several
mutants and he gives an example of
Marvel's what if so basically this
Disney Plus show for each episode that
we got could be about a different mutant
one episode could be about Rogue another
could be about Cyclops another could be
about storm then another about Wolverine
you get it and I got to say that would
be pretty dang cool I think almost
everybody would be there for that Disney
Plus show but Alex continues to state or
an X-Men film under the Marvel Studios
brand down the road prior to Avengers
secret War so a movie about the X-Men
titled the X-Men would come before
Secret Wars that way when all of the
X-Men show up in Avengers Secret Wars
past and present it wouldn't be that
confusing to the general population
which really isn't a bad idea on Marvel
side but check this out in this article
Alex States according to One Source
another idea that's been tossed around
involves an Avengers vers X-Men film set
between the members of the 616 Avengers
and the X-Men however it's still too
early to discuss as the X-Men have not
made their way to the 616 Universe yet
so the 616 Avengers versus the X-Men
would most likely come in the next Saga
after Avengers Secret Wars which does
make sense although I would love to see
that movie right now they do need to set
some stuff up before it actually happens
and if they tried to do that in the
Multiverse Saga it would probably be a
little too cramped but having them meet
each other the Avengers and the X-Men in
the midst of Kang or somebody else
another villain perhaps threatening the
Multiverse would force them to work
together if they all consider themselves
good guys and want to save the universe
they have to work together to stop this
ultimate Kang variant or whoever else
the villain could be but reports from
Alex Perez still suggest that Kang is
going to be the big bat at the end so in
a moment of crisis of course they'll
work with the Avengers but once
everything settles down and they have
time perhaps they don't actually get
along and maybe they don't agree with
the laws put in place by the countries
that they live in maybe there's a new
sovia Accords maybe they all end up in a
new universe and they can't agree on how
to proceed forward with it whatever it
could be at some point in time in the
MCU we should get an Avengers vers X-Men
film it just makes sense and fans would
love it but I don't think it makes sense
to come before Avengers secret War so
maybe in the next Saga what we've been
calling the mutant Saga we'll get an
Avengers vers X-Men film according to
sources that is being talked about right
now so we have an X-Men movie possibly
coming before Avengers Secret Wars a
Disney Plus show focusing on the
liveaction X-Men could be coming as well
and an Avengers vers X-Men film coming
after secret War so things are getting
really exciting for mutants in the MCU
but go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on the MCU and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series
X some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items as well the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of every month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof